we are actually going to do a new
segment and we're kicking it off right
now with none other than one of the
greatest chefs in the entire globe
ladies and gentlemen it's ann burrell
thank you so much for having me it's so
good to be here we're gonna kick off
um drew's cooking school that's right
and ann is gonna be the teacher now part
of drew's cooking school is for when
those people who don't feel so confident
in the kitchen need some guidance need
some you know
confidence we're going to say this
together because it's our new signature
segment are you ready everybody
it's time for
drew's cooking school
yeah
congratulations on your cooking school
now and i'm really excited about this
question what is one piece of advice you
have for people who aren't confident in
the kitchen all right i have two
straight out of the box and it's so
funny because when people are like i
don't know how to do stuff in the
kitchen i'm like well what happens when
you follow a recipe and they're like our
recipe
and i'm like what do you mean what do
you mean because if you don't know how
to get somewhere or how to do something
you look for a set of directions yes
that's what a recipe is but then the
other thing is is do your mise en place
and mise en place is a french term and
it means put in place it's the first
thing you learn in culinary school it's
the first thing i teach people when
they're starting off cooking it's do all
of your prep work first like cut your
onions cut your tomatoes get everything
out and get it ready so that when you
start to cook it's not a mad scramble to
find everything which is why you burn
everything and then feel like a failure
you feel stressed out and you have
dishes everywhere and food sucks all
right yeah exactly all right this is
great advice um now you're about to
teach a fool proof recipe to two of our
viewers who reached out um to us to
learn at our cooking school let's meet
them
hi drew my name is catherine and i'm a
mom of three i feel like people who have
an instinct for cooking have always had
that instinct and that is something i
just was not born with
i remember being intimidated by the
kitchen as a little girl so i didn't
even bother i took a cooking class a few
years ago however i just came across as
more of a class clown i have ruined
everything from chicken nuggets mac and
cheese pizza you name it you know you
can just cut around the burger part even
my kids have started teasing me and
wondering what is mom gonna make tonight
i could use help from a professional to
make a quick and simple recipe so i can
impress my family and friends
hi drew my name is tiffany grimes and i
desperately need your help when it comes
to cooking in the kitchen
i tend to mess up the simplest recipes
due to my disastrous cooking skills
and my busy work schedule which is
working and teaching full time i just
tend to eat out every
single day and it's really starting to
burn a hole through my pockets so i
would just love to learn some quick
simple dinner recipes that i could
master at home can someone help me
all right please welcome tiffany and
catherine
[Applause]
all right ann what are you teaching us
today so today we are making a super
delicious chicken milanese so it's a
breaded and fried chicken cutlet and
then it is topped with a little corn
tomato and red onion salad and of course
at this time of year basil and a little
arugula okay all right class officially
in session take us through it so we have
um a chicken breast that we have cut in
half so it's two
thin slices of a chicken breast but the
first thing when we're thinking about
raw chicken
anything that touches raw chicken you
have to wash your hands so let's just
glove up right now so we have our two
pieces of chicken we have a little saute
pan and we're just gonna beat our meat
like you know
it doesn't
just like me right that's what i always
say i'm amber and i'm inappropriate but
it's it's we're just gonna pound it a
little bit to flatten it so it's like
hit and drag there we go
there we go and that's it there we go
that's it that's it all right all right
so then we can put the little saute pan
aside so now what we're gonna do we're
gonna run these guys let's um season
them with salt so you want to do both
sides yes okay turn it over now a nice
even coating of salt
it's a nice light coating
one of the things i loved reading about
you is that you also want to be
economically minded when you eat yes so
ann is this dish an economically
friendly meal so you can chicken breasts
like honestly if you buy the whole
chicken and take the breast off your
chicken yourself then you have the
chicken breasts you have the chicken
legs you know the drums and the thighs
and then you have the carcass to make
chicken stock out of them you get a lot
of use out of that one chicken so buy a
whole chicken if you can give them
anywhere
so there we go so now we're going to go
through the standard breading procedure
so it's flour we dust it in the flour
shake off the excess flour
then egg wash so this is an egg beaten
together with a little bit of water
and then we're gonna go right into the
bread crumb and this is panko bread
crumbs they are japanese bread crumbs
they're nice big fixed shards and they
get extra crispy this is also mixed with
a little bit of parmesan cheese parmesan
oh that's a hot tip ann cause that adds
more salt and more umami flavor extra
can i ask you a question yes of course
what happens like one of my kids doesn't
like parmesan or any kind of cheese i
mean i bet you if you snuck the parmesan
in there and didn't tell them they
wouldn't even know
i don't know
if you feel like you know cheese averted
just leave it out okay all right so i'm
dropping my chicken in okay so there we
go and then i'm doing my second one
okay by the way catherine i gotta tell
you i really relate to you because my
children um when i serve them food let's
turn your pandas they're not like oh my
god mom this is amazing
they're you know um like little mini
food critics all of a sudden in the
kitchen and so i just really related to
your story of your kids not seeming
totally satisfied with your food and
you're doing your best there we go okay
so
we want a nice gentle fry very good look
at all these these look good right good
you see how you have a nice gentle fry
and then so it's not going to be like a
white water wrap is it's like sort of
like a jacuzzi it's right there and then
right exactly cooking can be done i find
it fun yeah you know cooking can also be
a hot freaking mess but you know what
that's okay because we're gonna go to a
commercial break and we're gonna
continue this journey and get our
confidence okay now that our chicken is
done first of all i just wanna show um
uh tiffany's chicken i think it looks
really good how are you feeling no i'm
actually feeling a little better now
i'm used to burning it so that came out
really good so now while these guys are
hanging out let's just whip together our
salad so we've done our mise en place we
have one ear of corn that's cut off the
cob it's raw corn you knew you could eat
raw corn i like raw corn me too i really
do you know what i also love out of the
can and it's my favorite word to say
niblets don't get me wrong i love a
counterpart
i love i'm creamed corn too i would pour
it all over my body
i really do you can i guess
you're right and i can
so then we have one beefcake tomato so
we've kept the um the gel and the seeds
because we're going to use this for our
vinaigrette by the way so we have some
red wine vinegar and olive oil we'll
take our uzi
yes the the um so it's like sort of a
tomato seed vinaigrette we're putting
this um and then are we emulsifying it
because i do love an emulsification well
yes go ahead whip it together um so we
have some onions that we're adding to
this we have one clove of garlic that
we're adding to our vinaigrette mint
mince right and then a little bit of
salt
we whip it together so we're just going
to stir this all together so pour it
right over there
i just know that i'm also a lot like
tiffany i'm really busy and i tend to
order take out a lot
and you know you want to stop the take
out habit and start cooking for yourself
and as a busy mom i really relate to
both of you my kids aren't cheering me
on in the kitchen and i don't have a lot
of time to cook for them and you're
thinking about the economical aspect and
i'm thinking about the psychology of
kind of i don't feel super empowered in
the kitchen it's a place that i really
love
but when it comes to like necessity it's
stressful so like what can we do to
empower you to take the stress out well
i have to say my 14 year old daughter
likes to cook i mean she likes to bake
so
i've actually helped her i've been more
of her assistant which has been good
that's been a way to bond i love that
it's it's been yeah it's a good thing i
bake with my kids all the time
but i will say um the cleanup is the
nightmare
right that's the other part to it right
but you know i'm like it's worth it
because it is really bonding and because
you're cooking with a kid like sometimes
as much as maybe you're not getting the
best
um
five star reviews for them at the same
time you can be so much more playful
with them oh yeah oh yeah so let's get
your basil in there and then just stir
it all up look at how beautiful that
looks my basil okay perfect
and then we have a plate with just a
little handful of arugula on the bottom
a little salad and i'd love to
take the chicken and put the warm
chicken
right on top of the salad so it kind of
wilts it a little bit
and then we spoon the salad over
and make sure that you get some of that
really yummy vinaigrette that's in the
bottom of there too so and just let it
kind of fall where it may it's kind of
like a confetti situation and there we
go and that's it that looks beautiful
wow right so you made it from start to
finish there you go i think i can do
this really i think i could do this do
you feel good about what you've done yes
and catherine how do you feel because
i'm looking at your dish and i'm here to
tell you that i think your dish looks
beautiful right yes it looks lovely and
fresh and delicious it's got rainbows so
i mean to me
cooking also especially when you're not
comfortable in the kitchen don't try to
go for the hardest thing that you've
ever tried to do i am always about the
low-tech solution like let's not make it
harder or more difficult like let's pick
a few ingredients that you're like oh i
really want to eat these and go around
those and just be respect them and be
kind to them and it doesn't have to take
a long time well i mean catherine i
think what you made is really beautiful
how do you feel about it i'm i'm feeling
empowered
[Applause]
i have to say though and you're a mom
and you could probably relate to this
but there is like a little chicken
finger thing that i could sort of use
with the kids you know absolutely i mean
i could say this is like a giant chicken
finger but with some
exactly
it's exactly what i mean think about it
let's try our dishes ladies and
gentlemen okay i'm really excited me too
okay
i am i'm i'm very very honored to be
taught by the great amber ale i'm very
honored to cook with two women who
i really relate to emotionally in the
kitchen
it was delicious
right it was delicious
it's like the the tomato seed
vinaigrette with the really pop of the
red wine vinegar and the garlic in there
i don't taste any parmesan also do you
no
oh
you just
get it
[Applause]
and and i think you have a little
surprise for somebody i do for both of
you ladies i'm going to
give you guys a a set of my cookware
that's available on hsn
[Applause]
thank you and they're dishwasher safe
you can you know they're right they're
nonstick you can use metal utensils and
then throw them right in the dishwasher
oh my god and i would like to stick with
you ladies and continue the culinary
journey this year will you do this with
me oh my gosh absolutely okay let's keep
this party going
[Music]